[Aplausos]
[Música]
a estas alturas del año 2021 quizás no
os hayáis dado cuenta pero este año ha
habido juegos olímpicos el evento
deportivo más importante del mundo se
acaba de celebrar en una de las ciudades
más fascinantes del planeta tokio la
capital del manga los samuráis y el
sushi pero nada de esto ha servido para
llamar vuestra atención y no lo digo yo
lo dicen los gatos la audiencia de tokio
2020 en la emb y si es la más baja desde
los juegos olímpicos del 88 la caída de
las audiencias ha sido catastrófica a
nivel global se mueve entre el 25 y el
30 por ciento y claro desde visual
política nos preguntamos cuál es el
verdadero interés de los juegos
olímpicos
porque no sé si sacar daréis pero hace
años los juegos olímpicos eran el sueño
húmedo de cualquier gobernante parecía
algo así como una verdad absoluta que
organizar unas olimpiadas era lo mejor
que podía pasar para poner a tu país en
el mapa los juegos olímpicos de
barcelona-92 sirvieron para mostrar que
españa era un país moderno y democrático
los de beijing-2008 mostraran el poderío
de la nueva china sin embargo tokio 2021
ha servido para mostrar las peores
vergüenzas de japón y no sólo es porque
el coronavirus haya chapado todas las
expectativas de turismo es que realmente
ha sido un fracaso lo mires por donde lo
mires atentos
estudio de la universidad de oxford los
juegos olímpicos de tokio son los juegos
de verano más caros los veteranos
seguidores de visual política ya
recordaréis que hace dos años
pronosticamos por aquí que tokio 2020
iba a ser una ruina y eso era cuando
pensábamos que al menos tokio recibiría
turistas pero es que con la pandemia del
coronavirus japón ha tenido que cerrar
las puertas de un país así que no han
tenido ningún turista 0-real de rihanna
así que la pregunta es hasta qué punto
estos juegos han sido una catástrofe
para japón veremos consecuencias
políticas y lo que nos toca más de cerca
a todos estamos ante el fin de los
juegos olímpicos tal y como lo conocemos
hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas
pero antes vamos a ver un poco de
historia
amorosino olímpico olimpiadas fantasma
lo de toque y los juegos olímpicos y es
una relación de amor-odio hablamos de un
gran éxito y demasiados sinsabores
veréis a lo largo de la historia lo que
ha presentado la candidatura olímpica
hasta cinco veces la primera vez fue en
1940 cuando los gobernantes de japón
querían mostrar el poderío de su imperio
el problema es que en 1940 acababa de
haber estallado la segunda guerra
mundial así que japón tuvo que renunciar
a organizar estos juegos olímpicos eso
sí en la memoria colectiva de japón
aquellos juegos de 1940 se recuerdan
como los
moros y no olímpico es decir las
olimpiadas fantasma dos décadas después
tu club volvió a la carga esta vez para
intentar hacerse con los juegos de 1960
pero no tuvo nada que hacer frente a la
candidatura de roma sin embargo mis
queridos amigos de visual política a la
tercera fue la vencida
e
tokio fue la sede de los juegos
olímpicos del 64 japón aprovecho para
decirle al mundo que ella se había
convertido en una democracia capitalista
la capital nipón ha reducido a cenizas
en el 45 emergió como una moderna
metrópolis se construyeron nuevas
carreteras e infraestructuras como el
tren bala del que tenéis más información
en el vídeo que le dedicamos en nuestro
canal mega projects
pero no sólo eso aquellos fueron los
primeros juegos olímpicos retransmitidos
vía satélite todo un milagro tecnológico
made in japan y como estos juegos
salieron también los japoneses quisieron
repetir la experiencia el problema el
problema es que el espíritu olímpico ha
cambiado y mucho
ahora los juegos han duplicado sus
dimensiones acude el doble de atletas
procedentes del doble de países y con el
doble de competiciones en disputa todo
esto se traduce en que organizar los
juegos olímpicos hoy en día supone una
auténtica fortuna carreteras hoteles
villa olímpica estadios y todo ello
solamente para utilizarse durante un mes
el mes que duran los juegos y diréis qué
pasa después pues se lo podéis preguntar
a los brasileños río luz e apocalíptica
a un año después de los juegos olímpicos
os presento la cara b de los juegos
olímpicos en las últimas tres décadas no
ha habido ni una sola olimpiada que haya
sido rentable sin embargo poco de esto
ha importado en 2019 el 90 por ciento de
los japoneses estaban entusiasmados con
los juegos de tokio 2020 así que los
yenes nunca faltaron y creerme hablamos
de muchos muchísimos llenas
[Música]
el presupuesto inicial era de 7 mil 300
millones de dólares pero el comité
organizado reconoció oficialmente que
estas cifras se elevaron hasta los 12
mil 600 millones el aplazamiento y las
medidas de prevención contra la cob y 19
añadieron otros 2 mil 800 millones para
hacer una factura final de 15 mil 400
millones de dólares sin embargo atentos
porque una auditoría del gobierno
japonés estimó en más de 28.000 millones
de dólares la inversión total
esta auditoría incluye el gasto de
infraestructuras que estudios como de la
universidad de oxford excluyen porque
consideran que son inversiones que japón
tarde o temprano tendría que acometer en
ese sentido los juegos de beijing o los
juegos invernales que rusia organizan
shocks y se llevan la medalla de oro en
cuanto a los más caros de la historia
pero si nos ceñimos al coste de
organizar los juegos es decir los
preparativos para esas semanas concretas
de competición deportiva tokio no tiene
rival han tirado la casa por la ventana
porque estos juegos eran la gran apuesta
del primer ministro shinzo abe una
oportunidad para decirle al mundo que
después de décadas de estancamiento
económico y catástrofes naturales japón
estaba de vuelta
en tren
y andy en treinta y treinta
me up con sense abad fukushima
la station es andar control
otro objetivo para el gobierno era
demostrar que el país no se ha quedado
atrás respecto a eeuu o china en lo que
a nivel tecnológico respecta durante
décadas japón fue la referencia en todo
lo que eran ordenadores televisiones y
videojuegos ahora querían aprovechar los
juegos olímpicos para marcar un nuevo
hito tecnológico en la historia del
olimpismo el programa es que dudo que
alguien se haya dado cuenta la nh k
transmitirá doscientas horas de los
juegos olímpicos de tokio en 8 k
efectivamente la televisión pública
japonesa se ha gastado un auténtico
fortuna en ofrecer retransmisiones en 8
k el problema que casi nadie tiene
televisiones en 8 k con lo cual pocos se
han dado cuenta de la calidad de las
transmisiones dicho de otra forma dinero
para nada pero esperad un momento porque
todavía no hemos terminado la historia
es aún peor atentos
[Música]
game over
akira es uno de los cómics japoneses más
míticos de la historia los otakus que
estáis viendo este vídeo no necesitáis
que os expliqué lo que es pero para los
que no lo conozcáis se trata de un cómic
publicado en el año 1982 pero ambientado
en 2019 en el cómic la ciudad de
neotokyo está a punto de celebrar unos
juegos olímpicos y la verdad es que el
retrato distópico de akira se
corresponde bastante con la realidad los
juegos olímpicos se llevarán a cabo bajo
el cuarto estado de emergencia por
coronavirus en tokio está claro que
estos juegos olímpicos han sido únicos
para empezar han sido en el año 2021 la
primera vez que se celebran en año impar
y todo para que al final las
restricciones sanitarias hayan impedido
que hubiera público las gradas aun así
el sucesor de shinzo abe el primer
ministro yoshihiko mantuvo su empeño en
celebrar los juegos olímpicos a toda
costa y todo eso a pesar de que la
pandemia estaba provocando casi cada día
10.000 muertes a lo largo del mundo sin
embargo japón se ha empeñado en
organizar los juegos olímpicos aunque
sabían que no iban a rentabilizar los
aunque sabían que no iba a haber
turistas esto era una decisión más
difícil entender que el final de akira
está os la dedico a vosotros mis
queridos seguidores otakus de visual
política es más para poderlos organizar
han tenido que poner unas restricciones
de lo más rocambolesco y acento es
porque aquí es cuando se
calienta la historia o más bien todo lo
contrario se permite el alcohol pero no
se distribuyen condones en la villa
olímpica de tokio habéis oído bien desde
el año 1988 se repartían condones en la
villa olímpica pensando bien los
deportistas son gente joven como el
cuerpo con la testosterona por las nubes
vamos que se montan unas nacho
binaria nash nunca mejor dicho pero en
época del cobi pues nada de condones de
verdad que no era más fácil pues poner
un año más los juegos olímpicos en
realidad no sólo lo digo yo y ésta era
la opinión mayoritaria de los japoneses
un 40 por ciento pedía un nuevo
aplazamiento y el otro 40% quería que
directamente tokio renunciara a los
juegos olímpicos pensadlo bien mientras
los japoneses tenían que soportar un
montón de restricciones han tenido que
ver cómo llegaban al país 50.000
deportistas de casi 200 países distintos
y todo ello porque
japón ha manejado lakovic 19 bastante
bien tiene 126 millones de habitantes
con una población notablemente
envejecida y aún así las muertes rondan
las 17.000 desde el comienzo de la
pandemia estos datos se deben a la
seriedad con la que los japoneses
respetaron las restricciones sin embargo
el 20 de agosto 12 días después de la
ceremonia de clausura hubo casi 26.000
positivos el día con más contagios desde
que comenzó la pandemia
y alguno pensará bueno pero al menos
habrán sacado alguna rentabilidad no se
preveía la creación de 2 millones de
empleos y un efecto positivo para la
economía nipona de 128 mil millones de
dólares gracias a la inversión al
turismo y al aumento de consumo
y si muchos pensaréis que estas
previsiones siempre están infladas pero
es que el resultado ha sido próximo a
cero ni siquiera han podido vender una
mísera entrada pero es que tampoco han
sacado provecho las grandes empresas
japonesas se gastaron un total de 3.600
millones de dólares en publicidad pero
los ciudadanos estaban tan cabreados con
los juegos olímpicos' ya está toyota
tuvo que retirar toda su publicidad
relacionada con los juegos a pesar de
ser uno de los principales
patrocinadores del coi
así que claro al final el legado de
tokio 2020 son solamente facturas y más
facturas os recuerdo los números 28.000
millones de dólares de los cuales 15 mil
400 es simplemente el coste de organizar
el mes de la competición pues bien de
todo este pastizal todo menos seis mil
setecientos millones de dólares van a
salir de los bolsillos del contribuyente
japonés hablamos de una millonada con la
que se podrían construir 300 hospitales
o 1200 escuelas de educación primaria
como os podéis imaginar lo que ha batido
récords es la impopularidad del primer
ministro suba un hombre para el que ya
no habrá más pantallas ni de 8k ni de hd
yo sí he de zug a dejará el cargo de
primer ministro de japón con sudor fuera
de combate su sucesor tendrá que
enfrentarse a unas elecciones generales
antes de que acabe el mes de noviembre a
ver quién les cuenta ahora los japoneses
que hay que subir los impuestos porque
lo cierto es que la deuda de japón ha
alcanzado ya unas dimensiones tan
colosales que a su lado con chila
aparece una lagartija y muchos les
preguntaréis pero esto qué consecuencias
puede tener para el resto del mundo pues
lo cierto es que tiene muchas
consecuencias y ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver
y la llama olímpica se apaga
los juegos olímpicos son como las bodas
es un derroche de dinero para disfrutar
de un momento que francamente luego pasa
muy rápido aún así organizarlos es el
sueño húmedo de cualquier país todavía
recuerdo cuando madrid optaba organizar
los juegos olímpicos ya podía uno tener
cuidado con eso es decir que estabas en
contra porque todo el mundo y digo
literalmente todo el mundo se te echaba
al cuello al final madrid perdió ante
tokio pero a los españoles nos dejó
grandes momentos como por ejemplo el
inglés tan impecable de la por entonces
alcaldesa de madrid que trataba de
persuadir al comité olímpico
internacional con este discurso digno
del mismísimo winston churchill o la
mismísima margaret thatcher
ayer you know and celebrate live like
spanish people
there is nothing like relax sin cabos
café con leche en plaza mayor
wayne romantic dinner y en el madrid de
los austrias
a estas alturas muchos estáis
preguntando que que tenemos aquí en
visual política en contra de los juegos
olímpicos a ver no solamente hablamos
del enorme desembolso de dinero que
nunca llega a rentabilizarse y que solo
cuesta dinero a los contribuyentes
tampoco hablamos de todas esas
infraestructuras que no sirven para nada
una vez terminan los juegos también hay
un tercer problema y ese es la
corrupción porque ganarse a los miembros
del coi el comité olímpico internacional
es bastante complicado y caro el coi es
una de las organizaciones
internacionales que mejor vive en todo
el planeta cada vez que visitan una
ciudad candidata reciben un trato de
lujo y según se ha revelado en varias
ocasiones las cámaras que les ponen no
son las camas de cartón que ponían a los
pobres deportistas en tokio precisamente
el coi expulsó a varios miembros por
corrupción a finales de los años 90
habían sido comprados para llevar los
juegos olímpicos de 2002 a salt lake
city pero no era un caso aislado la
capital de yuta había adoptado esta
estrategia después de perder antena ganó
en el 98 la candidatura japonesa regaló
ordenadores la ciudad mormona repartió
caramelos y sombreros de vaquero también
se desveló que varios miembros del coi
habían pedido a la candidatura de
melbourne para 1996 coches nuevos y
gastos pagados en los mejores burdeles
de la ciudad australiana melbourne no
aceptó y aquellos juegos se celebraron
en atlanta ya os lo hemos dicho los
miembros del coi no duermen en camas de
cartón
[Música]
está claro que los deportistas se
entienden entre ellos dentro de la villa
olímpica pero las del comité olímpico
hay que darles un trato realmente
profesional y con denominación de origen
para que no tengan dudas sobre dónde hay
que celebrar los juegos y por supuesto
todo eso lo pagan los contribuyentes del
país el problema es que la gente cada
vez les tiene más calados los fracasos
económicos de río o de tokio son
notorios y la audiencia televisiva sigue
cayendo por eso cada vez hay menos
interés en organizar el mega evento
olímpico y los miembros del coi se están
cansando de ver noticias como estas
hamburgo vota no en el referéndum de los
juegos olímpicos de 2024 juegos
olímpicos de roma 2024 la alcaldesa rag
y dice no él sigue a la candidatura es
irresponsable de repente el coi se
encontró con sólo dos candidaturas por
organizar los juegos de 2024
parís y los ángeles a la vista del
panorama optó por una decisión
salomónica pues hoy en parís 2024 y los
ángeles 2028 que ya os digo pobrecitos
menuda les ha caído dicho de otra forma
que por fin hay algo que está cambiando
en el olimpismo de tener varias
candidaturas pegándose por obtener el
favor del coi a ver cómo las
candidaturas prácticamente se presentan
a escondidas es más ahora parece que es
el coi el que va por el mundo suplicando
hoy en mirada a ver si queréis celebrar
los juegos olímpicos en vuestra ciudad y
sin comerlo ni beberlo nos hemos
encontrado con que ya tenemos sede para
los juegos de 2032 en este caso no ha
habido ninguna competición no había
rival sin embargo mirad el teatrillo que
hacen para darle un poco de emoción a la
cosa
[Música]
dos cosas tengo muy claras ahora mismo
una es que el 90% de vosotros os acabáis
de enterar de de beers pain otra es que
para ver a quien colocarle los juegos
los del coi vieron el vídeo que hicimos
sobre porque australia es tan rica
dentro de 11 años cuando se celebra en
estos juegos
estoy seguro de que os acordaréis de
visual polític per mientras tanto la
pregunta es para vosotros creéis que los
juegos olímpicos de tokio se recordarán
como un símbolo de superación o como una
catástrofe tenemos juegos olímpicos para
rato o la llama olímpica de verdad corre
peligro de apagarse definitivamente y la
pregunta más importante que ofrecería es
alcoy para que vuestra ciudad organizará
los juegos olímpicos queremos conocer
las respuestas más originales y más
ocurrentes que seguro que va a ser muy
divertido podéis dejarnos vuestra
respuesta en los comentarios y como
siempre no olvidéis que aquí en visual
político sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las
semanas así que suscribiros a este canal
y darle a la campanita para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones si
os ha gustado este vídeo dadle a like y
nos vemos en el próximo un abrazo y
hasta pronto
[Música]